what's going on guys spring is coming
which means it's time for another season
of Game of Thrones but with so much
intrigue in Westeros it's easy to forget
exactly what the hell's going on that's
why we're here to bring you up to speed
strap on your Valyrian steel turn down
that wedding invitation it's time for
the idiots guide to Game of Thrones
season four
oh and by the way yeah there's gonna be
a lot of spoilers let's start it off in
King's Landing with everyone's favorite
dysfunctional family
the Lannisters fresh off red wedding the
stark family the Lannisters are getting
ready for a wedding of their own King
Joffrey and everyone's favorite gold
digger Margaery Tyrell let's face it if
it's got a crown she's down just when it
seems like everything is going according
to plan
Joffrey chokes on his wine and we get to
witness the most anticipated television
deaths since ever
someone has poisoned the king you know
seeing that terrified look in Joffrey's
eyes makes it easy to sympathize with
the dude so let me just say I hope your
death was twice as painful as it looked
good riddance you soulless monster of
course Joffrey's mom aunt Cersei
immediately blames her son's death on
the most hated member of the family
Tyrion Lannister he poisoned my son
Tyrion is arrested and put on trial
which gives Peter Dinklage an amazing
scene to put on his reel I did not kill
Joffrey but I wish that I had he demands
a trial by combat and why not it worked
for him way back in season one with bran
knocked that fool at the moon door but
this time it looks like nobody's gonna
stand for him tyrians brother Jaime is
fresh lead II handed antarians bodyguard
bran is like yeah it's not worth it just
one all seems lost enter my personal
favorite new character Oberyn Martell
the red Viper of Dorne there will be
your champion
haven't are much about Dorn on this show
except for their wine and their women
what's the strangest thing you do
Dornish girls count oberyn's out for
revenge against the mountain the man
personally responsible for killing the
red Vipers family and was it cause that
just I'm sure I'm gonna get to enjoy
this character for years to come
I'll never eat melon again Tywin
sentences his least favorite son to
death but Jamie's good guy streak kicks
in any Springs tyrion from jail on his
way out of Dodge Tyrion decides to tie
up a few loose ends and take care of his
former lover / prostitute / witness for
the prosecution Shae and Papa Tywin who
he cross bows to death while he's
sitting on the not so iron throne I have
always been your son finally Tyrion
escapes King's Landing in a crate it's
an infinite box huh okay that's enough
Lannister talk with all this talk about
King's Landing it's easy to forget about
our favorite Westeros family the Starks
Tyrians wife Sansa hooks it out of
King's Landing as Joffrey is dying with
the help of Sir Dontos the drunken
Knight whose life she saved back in
season two you caught as it turns out
grandma Tyrell was behind Joffrey's
poisoning you don't think I'd let you
marry that beast deal and use Dontos to
give Sansa a necklace to smuggle the
poison into the wedding killing a man at
a wedding what sort of monster would do
such a thing
now Margaery Tyrell is free to start
seducing Joffrey's younger brother
Tommen the new king leave it to Game of
Thrones for the courtship between an
adult woman and a child to be the
sweetest relationship on the show but
back to Sansa now she's in the clutches
of the creepiest guy in Westeros Petyr
Littlefinger Baelish what do you want
everything
Sansa lets Littlefinger take her to the
Eyrie home of her aunt Lysa
everything seems to be going great until
Lysa sees her new
little finger kissing Sansa which leads
to a reasonable discussion that clears
up the misunderstanding just kidding
now Sansa Stark emerges as a player in
the game of Thrones instead of
Littlefinger's pawn while we're on the
subject of Starks let's get to the
obligatory recap of what's going on with
bran he's still getting dragged around
north of the wall by Hodor who drew a
company by the Wonder Twins Jojen and
Meera read bran keeps getting visions
telling him to find a big tree I know we
have to go the foursome almost make it
to Brad's mystical tree when they're
attacked by an army of Ray Harryhausen
skeletons from jason and the argonauts
and Jojen winds up taking a dirt nap
even though he's still alive in the
books take that book readers it's the
wild wild west roast now nobody's safe
even your beloved Jojen Reed dead you
know nothing bran finally makes it to
his magic tree and meets the three-eyed
crow who promises to show brand all
sorts of cool magic stuff that's gonna
take place completely off screen during
season 5 sorry bran
you'll live awoke again but you will fly
and put a bow on the stark family we
have the bad assest of them all Arya
she's on the most mismatched road trip
since rush hour with the Hound who
apparently is a big fan of chickens I
understand that if any more words come
pouring out your mouth I'm gonna have to
eat every [ __ ] chicken in this room
but re and houndstooth shirt when they
meet up with big ol Brienne of Tarth
there's no safe - you dumb [ __ ] you
don't know that by now you're the wrong
one to watch over her The Hound of
Brienne have an epic fight and roided-up
Tilda Swinton wins ah ah really verb e
FF to die he'll make hay and cash is in
the coin she got from the faceless
assassin Jacquin Hegar if the day comes
when you must find me again just give
that coin to any man from Braavos and
say these words - Valar morghulis Valar
morghulis
now Arya is on a boat headed straight to
Braavos presumably to become even more
of a badass while we're on the subject
of badass women of Westeros Daenerys
Targaryen the Khaleesi is continuing her
freedom tour with her package 'less army
of unsullied first she frees
slave city of murine then she decides
not to grab the Iron Throne just yet but
ruler kingdom of freed slaves and hang
out on a really picturesque balcony for
a while I will not sail for Westeros I
will do what Queens do I will rule what
do you want George RR Martin's a slow
writer they got a feel time somehow the
mother of dragons is joined by her
right-hand man sir friendzone jorah
mormont everything is going great for
sir friendzone until he gets his ass
exiled when Daenerys finds out he
started out as a spy who helps set up
her assassination attempt in season 1 I
want him dead mother and child both the
princess is with child based on whose
information sir Jorah moment come on
sure to make things worse Daenerys has
to chain up two of her three dragons
when she finds out they've turned an
innocent little girl into a Kentucky
Fried corpse by the way people of
Westeros there's a rogue dragon flying
around watch the skies and finally
everyone's favorite bastard Jon Snow
he's made it back to the wall after a
season of hanging out with the wildlings
and boning Ygritte in a cave king of the
wildlings Mance Rayder is marching
towards the wall and only John and his
crow Bros stand between them Mance's
army attacks and it's like a fantasy
fans wet dream you've got mammoths
you've got Giants you've got a giant
site that annihilates people climbing
the wall the crows win the day
but Jon loses his wildling girlfriend
Ygritte who shot through the heart and
dies
Egret I love you but that phrase is
becoming the that's what she said of
Game of Thrones
John ventures forth into the wilderness
to take out Mance Rayder but before he
can do it fat dead King's brother
Stannis Baratheon storms in and mows
down the wildling army and it looks like
fire has finally met ice as the lord of
lights biggest disciple teams up with
Ned Stark's bastard son you're speaking
to the one true king boy I know he's the
king my father died for it so why do we
leave out did you want to hear more
about [ __ ] wonder Theon Greyjoy's
return to Winterfell what about the
brief return of hot pie or that white
Walker that turned that baby's eyes an
icy blue that was weird
let us know in the comments below best
answer we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank you guys
for watching I'm hollering hit me up on
Twitter by like lady and tramping mean
we're both gonna eat it at the same time
yeah oh god don't look at me okay no I
loved it I'm making a weird I'll raise
my eye here we go no you lip quivering
dude I'd like you wanna suck it yeah I
know what it's not